Okay.
So now we're going to go back in time to Sumeria and I'm going to show you how
this scenario creation myth lays itself out.
And not only that,
I'm going to describe to you the direct political implications of the new my
list,
a Sumerian creation,
Beth,
because the political implications of that myth are well understood because the
political structure of Sumeria was directly associated with the structure of the
myth because the Sumerian emperor was regarded as the earthly representative of
the highest God in the Mesopotamian Pantheon whose name was Marduk.
So in so far as you were emperor,
the reason that you were emperor,
and this is what gave your sovereignty legitimacy,
right?
Cause sovereignty has to have legitimacy,
otherwise there's constant revolutions.
What gave sovereignty legitimacy in Mesopotamia was the identification of the
emperor with Marduk and that hat that had certain implications for the emperor,
which we'll discuss in some detail.
The story starts like this.
You've got this drag tie a mat.
And timeout is a great primordial
beast who lives at the bottom of the ocean and the ocean is water and water is
associated with the primal element in archaic thinking.
And I told you there's reasons for that already.
If you viewed the transformation of deserts has a consequence of rain,
can understand why water would be considered the element that gives life,
right?
That the element that that brings life fourth.
And we know from an evolutionary perspective that that's accurate.
And we know that we're 90% water and so to consider water,
the primal element is no trivial conclusion.
No,
no less than presuming that the sun is the ultimate source of life,
the ultimate God,
because the sun is the ultimate source of life as far as we're concerned on
earth,
right?
Cause it's the source of all our energy.
These aren't stupid concepts.
All right?
So timeout is this horrible creature that lurks at the bottom of the primal
element.
All right?
Now she has a husband Appsu.
Now the massive detain me and creation myth doesn't say much about Appsu.
We only know that he's the male con,
sort of the dragon of chaos.
And we know from reading other sources of mythology that the male consort of the
dragon of chaos generally represents either logos or culture.
So we're going to make the presupposition in this particular case that the
husband of chaos is order or culture.
Okay.
And then the Mesopotamians don't say much about that.
That that doesn't,
the development of the idea of apps who are order or culture doesn't,
it doesn't take new force until the ancient Egyptians.
We'll talk about them today too.
Okay,
so ty about naps who are locked into a kind of sexual embrace according to the
Mesopotamian creation myth.
And what does that mean?
It kind of means two things.
It means that they're not really distinguishable because they're locked into
this embrace.
And it also means that they're up to something creative because the act of
sexual congress in mythology is most usefully,
is most frequently utilized,
has representation of something creative or as representation of the probability
of some new form coming to be.
Right.
All right,
so abso in timeout are locked into this embrace in a state that other creation
myths describe as egg.
Like the pre cosmo Gornick egg,
there are intermingling gives rise to the initial state of being according to
the Sumerians.
And the initial state of being according to the Sumerians is characterized by
the dominion of the elder gods.
These gods being none too bright,
make a tremendous amount of rack doing things well.
What does that mean exactly?
Well,
it means something like this.
They make a lot of racket and they cause a lot of trouble.
They make a lot of wind and all of the racket and trouble and wind and activity
rouses tie amat.
What does that mean?
Well,
it means if you do things and get in trouble,
it means even if you're trying to solve problems,
you get into trouble because the solution to a problem,
Chin tends to generate a whole bunch of new problems,
right?
It's like the Hydra.
So what it means is that it's more or less fated that any form of activity
whatsoever
is likely to produce the threat of catastrophe.
And of course,
we're absolutely keenly aware of that in the modern world because we are
possessed by this sense that all of our frenetic activity,
all of our frenetic motivated activity is producing alterations in the world
order such that nature itself is going to be destroyed and eliminate us.